questions uh scenarios scenario uh you
girls you're dating a guy for less than
a month
you're dating though it's not like
official but it's at that phase where
it's like you've been on dates it's
clearly a thing but it's not boyfriend
and girlfriend you're dating a dude less
than a month you get invited on a
Millionaire's yacht with all your
girlfriends yeah what do you tell your
guy that I got invited on a
Millionaire's job with all my
girlfriends we're gonna go have fun
okay and you want him to be cool with
that yeah because I want him to be able
to trust me when I go on Yachts or bows
I'm not going on these boats to try to
get with a guy okay when he says it
would make me really uncomfortable if
you go on this yacht and do this sort of
yacht thottery uh I would prefer you
don't go yeah what would you say you
know that's an interesting question I
would say maybe we are not meant to be I
know I would have happened
yeah baby what if he was making the 50
million so I think I would also have a
conversation with him and I'd be like
hey what's making you feel this way what
can I do to make you feel more secure
what has made you feel insecure in the
past and talk about like our baggage I
would definitely have a conversation I'm
sure but I also think wants to do talk
about his bag yeah exactly okay real
quick real quick answers not questions
um what would you do in that exact same
scenario you get invited on a
Millionaire's yacht uh what would you
tell your new man you've been together
less than a month less than a month and
he knows you do only fans
okay okay yeah I I would say I'm going
on the yacht
straight up yeah okay especially less
than a month I'm not sure you're dating
a dude it's been a month you get invited
on a yacht you're here in Miami you've
never been on a yet I don't know if you
have it or not you invited on a
Millionaire's yacht what would you say
to your man
um and this guy's he's husband material
he's yeah you're dating him who cares
what is the yacht guy gonna marry me no
okay so why am I throwing away a good
relationship for a dude that like he
doesn't want to would you tell him I say
hey by the way I got him by this yacht
what would you like me to do that's
happened to me before I got a really
good like when I was smaller I got a
really good collab in my boyfriend at
the time said that he wasn't okay with
it I didn't go yeah okay until we broke
up gosh then when you broke up did you
feel like you wish you went
um no because I felt like I was loyal to
him like I I that's who I you know yeah
but he said not committed I'm not
committing to any man until he's
committing to me so until then I do what
I want well you know be careful what you
wish for because with that attitude he
may never commit to you
then I find the next man
for me like I really value like um
somebody who's comfortable and confident
and like lets me just I don't know
especially like okay say we go out
together we typically like me and my
boyfriends will separate and we're both
lives of the party are talking to
everyone we come back and we're like
yeah we're a team and then we go do our
thing and they're comfortable with me
like hanging out talking to friends I
would view that the same thing like I'm
here with my girls we're on only fans
like we do only bands I don't know but
this is the same problem I was talking
about with my brother dating an only
fans girl because it's me before us when
it should be us first like how are you
gonna have a family when it's money when
it's my fam my feelings and my emotions
before us so how do you know though as a
woman that that man is actually
committed like you're saying he's stupid
you will say it so you don't really know
you don't even know it's not even
committed yet yeah you've only been
dating a month
you're never gonna know but you have to
go into things with good faith because
you have previous trauma you can't put
that on a guy who's done enough he's
taking his previous trauma assuming
here's actually what happens here's what
happens
you don't tell him or I would never not
tell him okay okay let's say you do
let's go down the list here
number one Pearl's thing is let me tell
you up front if he says Hey prefer you
don't go she doesn't go if he says hey
cool I trust you at least he knows he
give the blessing let's say you don't
tell him okay or let's say he let's say
um you kind of say well listen I know
this makes you uncomfortable but I'm
gonna do it anyway here's what happens
there's this thing called Instagram
and uh he's gonna
see something on Instagram of
and if you're on a yacht and you're in
Miami and there's chicks on the yacht
there is thottery like no other
shout out to the guys with the yacht who
are helping these ladies live in their
dreams and he's going to see this he's
going to see twerking going on he's
going to see bikinis going on there's
gonna probably be 10 dudes and 50 women
okay and he's gonna see this and what
he's gonna think is like
just another trick ass hoe in Miami I
actually like this girl and he's just
gonna be like ah
I don't know so what you need to ask
yourself as a woman is to say
do I actually see myself with this guy
do I give a [ __ ] about his feelings if
so maybe I shouldn't go on this yacht or
if the answer is you gotta accept me for
am I if you don't accept me and my words
they don't deserve me and my best kind
of a thing
how is he showing me that he's looking
at my emotions and trying to make sure
that I'm doing what I want to do as well
if I'm only looking out for him is he
not then supposed to look out for me if
we're a team fair question fair question
but life is not fair because men do not
like promiscuous women women actually
appreciate a dude that can get some
[ __ ]
that's just the way life Works
absolutely you're absolutely right every
girl in my show comes on and says how
they hate cheaters blah blah blah but
the only X you'll talk about is the one
that cheated on you that's the only one
you talk about I don't hear any stories
from the boring guy who is faithful to
you never yeah and you've never had one
of those and you know and you know and
you know if if he's in her mouth she
still loves him on something I would say
if the man if I like he's showing all
the right signs like good communication
skills like he's showing me that he's
like he wants me yeah I would definitely
have a conversation and in that
conversation I would gauge what kind of
man he is is he asking like and he feels
uncomfortable for x y and z
some of those reasons to me wouldn't be
valid but some of them and I think like
a a certain man could show me and I'd be
like you know what maybe that's not the
best idea if we were dating and a man's
uncomfortable then I'm absolutely gonna
listen last question but I'm not going
to if that becomes a habit that every
time I want to go out my friends you're
like no staying this is a headache to a
guy of a girl that doesn't listen and he
has to argue with every time he asks her
to do something
disagreeable women I have to stop it
here because we got to go by the way you
guys are all invited on my yacht this
weekend so uh inform whatever boyfriend
you need to do last question then we'll
do Super Chat so we're gonna wrap up
um
let's say you meet this dude it's a
great dude the man you're thinking of
it's great he's making 70k he's killing
it he's making you know 100 he's doing
his thing you meet the dude you meet the
dude okay of your dreams all right
um how willing are you if he's willing
to commit
how willing are you to submit where he's
the boss he's the leader you're the
co-pilot yeah how willing are you to be
that girl for your for your man but he's
the leader oh very well very willing
you're willing take me away I don't want
to you think about anything just you go
tell me what to do and I'll do it okay
yeah how about you I'm very willing
that's what I'm looking for I don't know
yourself that's not what you're
with him every time I think having a
conversation labeling it as an argument
is completely problem let's come and see
it I'm not I don't know man sees it
that's not my man having to have no
that's how men see it having to have a
conversation so that sounds like it's
like it's a headache control it's yeah
we need to be able to communicate that's
what happens when you submit you give
him control
um all right I will leave it right there
with that
um ladies this has been very uh
Illuminating this is amazing as many of
you know you know is just banned on on
talk and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible